momento de hablar de economía aquí en
France 24 me acompaña en el estudio
Jorge Hurtado Jorge bienvenido vamos a
hablar del impacto que ha tenido la
gripe aviar en América Latina y la
incidencia en el comercio también en las
exportaciones Y por supuesto en las
producciones de esos países cuéntenos
bueno es que el continente lleva a
Santiago ya varios meses lidiando con la
influenza aviar que se expande por
varios países y que está dejando miles
de aves muertas o sacrificadas y en la
región de América Latina la enfermedad
llegó por aves migratorias contagiadas
lo que está provocando mortandad también
en aves silvestres lobos marinos y aves
de traspaso algunos países como Colombia
y México reportaron los primeros casos
en octubre del año pasado en México por
ejemplo se infectaron casi seis millones
de aves según la secretaría de
agricultura de ese país mientras en
Colombia hubo 49 focos en nueve
departamentos pero lograron controlarla
a tiempo una situación que es aún más
compleja en Perú chile y Argentina
conversamos con Gonzalo Moreno él es
presidente de la federación Nacional de
avicultores de Colombia benavi sobre el
impacto en la industria y esto nos dijo
cada país a Toño que tomara unas
decisiones muy duras sobre todo en
materia de fusil sanitario para poder
contener Pero al final es una enfermedad
que tiene una alta mortalidad solamente
en los últimos años han habido más de
250 millones de aves muertas es una
pandemia ya de influenza Vial para el
sector Avícola en general en todo el
planeta es el gran reto en el cual nos
encontramos en este momento el impacto
directo es por la mortalidad de las aves
porque puede llegar a tener una
mortalidad al 80 90 por ciento y en
ciclos productivos como el del huevo en
el cual Desde que la ave nace hasta que
empieza a poner huevos son más o menos
son 16 semanas y pone por dos años
entonces reconstruir esa cadena es muy
difícil y ahí se ve el impacto ha pasado
en todos los países que ha tenido casos
de influencia vial en aves comerciales
en los cuales tenido que hacer fusil
sanitario preventivo para no disemar
para no para que no se Esparza la
enfermedad por por el país y eso al
final tiene consecuencias en la oferta
de huevo para las personas de pago los
países que han tenido casos en pagos y
de pollo también Jorge Qué otros países
están enfrentando desafíos al respecto
bueno entre los más afectados está
Argentina ese país detectó el primer
caso A mediados de febrero y decidió
Cancelar sus exportaciones de apoyo y
huevo al exterior Argentina produce
anualmente 2,5 millones de toneladas de
pollo de las que exporta el 13% el año
pasado exportó 420 millones de dólares
en productos avícolas como carne de
pollo y huevos su principal es destinos
son la Unión Europea China y Arabia
Saudita la situación es compleja porque
también la producción Avícola emplea
directamente a unas 130.000 personas en
todo el país según datos de la cámara
Argentina de productores agrícolas pero
los productores ahí atraviesan una de
las peores sequías en décadas y el
gobierno Busca los dólares provenientes
de las exportaciones para intentar
frenar la inflación que supera ya el
100% anual por su parte en Chile la
gripe aviar ya provocó Un aumento en los
precios más de medio millón de gallinas
ponedoras murieron o Fueron sacrificadas
por este virus así lo cuenta nuestra
corresponsal Patricia Luna
si les ha visto bastante afectado por la
gripe agraria que llegó al país en
diciembre pasado procedente de aves
migratorias del hemisferio norte que
afecta ya a 40 especies uno de los
sectores más impactados ha sido de la
producción de huevos que ya venía
afectado por un incremento en el 35% en
el último año en el precio de este
alimento impulsado sobre todo por el
alza del Maíz según las autoridades de
los 12.000 productores de huevos que
existen en chile se ha visto afectado
105 de ellos lo que representa un 5% del
total y se traduce en 700.000 aves
ponedoras de huevos y más de 10.000 aves
muertas esto ha incrementado un 2% más
el precio de los huevos en las últimas
semanas un alimento bastante común en la
dieta de los chilenos mientras algunas
organizaciones medioambientales
aprovechan la coyuntura para recordar el
sistema de producción intensivo que
caracteriza a la industria en el país
porque así con esta panorama que usted
nos está explicando qué dicen entonces
las autoridades sobre el avance que ha
tenido esta enfermedad justamente ahí en
Chile el director de la organización
Panamericana de la salud harvas Barbosa
advirtió que la gripe aviar puede
afectar al suministro de pollo en la
región y que esto tendría un golpe en la
seguridad alimentaria el director de la
vps que es el brazo Regional de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud aseguró
que hay influencia aviar en
prácticamente todos los países del Sur
del continente le preguntamos si el
director de la federación Nacional de
avicultores de Colombia que hizo su país
para controlar el brote y esto Dijo
no obstante nosotros venimos trabajando
primero en la radicación de la
enfermedad desde el año 2008 se tomó una
decisión entre el estado y el gremio en
el cual se declaró como enfermedad de
control oficial la influenza Vial y el
newcastle desde ese momento hemos venido
implementado normas de bioseguridad cada
granja que tenga más de 200 aves tiene
que ser una granja Avícola biosegura
pero el éxito sin duda de del control de
la influenza hablar fue que ante casos
sospechosos se procedió a la
erradicación Y tenemos una respuesta muy
rápida de laboratorio que en menos de 24
horas que se tenga el resultado se que
se tenga la muestra se tiene el
resultado y se puede atacar el foco y el
perifoco Fue una fue una actividad muy
dura no obstante logramos contenerla en
zonas específicas y no se extendió en
todo el país Jorge Pues muchas gracias
por este especial de economía y ustedes
pueden seguir en sintonía de France 24
sigan con nosotros
[Música]